[Musica]
ho portato due dadi con me
uno è un comune dado con sei facce
numerate dall 1 al 6
l'altro andato con 10 facce se lo lancio
qualsiasi valore dall 1 al 10 alla
stessa probabilità di uscire
ora giochiamo voi lanciate lato da 10
facce io quello da sei vincete a questo
gioco sotto rete un numero uguale o più
grande del mio
7 a 5 complimenti avete vinto la giocata
vincere con il ad hoc da 10 faccia è più
facile ma sapreste dirmi
approssimativamente qual è la vostra
probabilità di vincere a questo gioco un
possibile approccio si basa
sull'esperienza mi spiego posso lanciare
ripetutamente i dadi e prendere nota di
ogni vittoria dopo 100 lanci ne renderai
conto di vincere all'incirca sette o
otto volte ogni giocata con un po di
pazienza e mille lanci capirai che la
probabilità di vittoria si avvicina al
75 per cento con l'aumentare di lanci la
mia stima basata sulla media dei
successi diventa più precisa questo
oltre a essere intuitivo è garantito
dalla legge dei grandi numeri
poi se ritenete un pò tedioso danzare
dei dadi mille volte ma possiamo farlo
fare un computer
il vostro portatile dovrebbe riuscire a
lanciare all'incirca 100 milioni di dadi
in un solo secondo
questo tipo di approccio a un problema
matematico le soluzioni in problema
matematico si chiama metodo montecarlo
per per questa capacità del computer di
simulare il caso è un metodo
potentissimo possiamo simulare un lancio
dei dadi
ma anche il comportamento di un fluido
oppure l'evoluzione di una colonia di
batteri o di un epidemia o addirittura
l'andamento di interi sistemi finanziari
per dare risposte al gioco dei dadi
non abbiamo avuto bisogno di nessuna
matematica un matematico puro riterrebbe
il metodo montecarlo poco elegante come
se avessimo abusato della forza bruta
dell'informatica
a noi sembra piuttosto una forma di
magia e per questo quattro anni fa ho
iniziato il mio dottorato in metodo di
montecarlo all'università di warwick in
inghilterra
ora ripongo i dadi
non voglio parlarvi di matematica oggi
voglio raccontarvi un capitolo della mia
storia
purtroppo la magia dei metodi montecarlo
che aveva tanto stregato è svanita dopo
le 8 la prima settimana di dottorato
l'ambiente di lavoro auorità eccezionale
o mio ufficio è un supercomputer
seminari conferenze sono all'ordine del
giorno
e i due professori che mi seguono solo
di un intelligenza competenza e umanità
impareggiabili
ma il dottorato non fa per tutti il
dottorato estremamente difficile tecnico
spesso frustrante poiché è basato sulla
ricerca innovativa dietro ad ogni idea
vincente ci sono dieci cento tentativi
falliti e l'odorato può essere un
percorso solitario
io passa la maggior parte del mio tempo
da solo di fronte al computer o un
articolo di statistica per affrontare
questi ostacoli sarebbe una passione
solidissima di cui io non ero provvisto
ecco menti in movimento
sembra un tema servito su un piatto
d'argento per un matematico che studia
all'estero ma io vi posso garantire che
in quel momento la mia mente era più che
ferma paralizzata
pochi mesi dopo l'inizio del dottorato
ho iniziato ad insegnare
ero così teso pensate insegnare
matematica e in inglese per la prima
lezione di 40 minuti mi sono preparato
più di due settimane ma con quella prima
lezione se scendevo un fuoco dentro di
me li determinazione e motivazione
finalità tutto quello che prima mancava
e per quale motivo
perché tutta quell'euforia non
interessava rispondere a questa domanda
mi sentivo rigenerato volevo mantenere
questo stato di euforia è così qui ci
sono buttato a capofitto
ho iniziato a vivere di lezione in
lezione e non mi bastava essere non mi
passava una preparazione solida volevo
appassionare i miei studenti
coinvolgerli sorprenderli e farli
divertire
cercavo di sfruttare ogni opportunità ha
ottenuto un diploma in didattica
universitaria sono passati insegnare da
due ore a studenti del primo anno a più
di otto ore anche di costi più avanzati
maggiore era il carico di lavoro che di
dal tavo efficiente forte e determinato
e poi per me non si trattava di lavoro
ortonovo realizzazioni in ogni aspetto
dell'insegnamento preparare la lezione è
un processo creativo stimolante una
forma d'arte
mi piace perfino correggere i compiti
leggere i dagli studenti giuste o
sbagliate che siano
porta un apprendimento continuo e poi
sarà il momento della performance in
classe diventa uno show man e l'aula al
mio palcoscenico la lezione al mio
spettacoli la gratitudine degli studenti
ripagava ampiamente tutta la mia fatica
e io stavo imparando da loro tanto
quanto loro stavo imparando da ma nel
corso del terzo anno arriva anche un
riconoscimento concreto
l'università di world league mi assegna
il premio per l'eccellenza
nell'insegnamento come giovane
ricercatore nel corso del mio dottorato
o ottenuto tante soddisfazioni ma questa
e suonava dentro di ma in maniera
diversa era stato tutto così naturale
bello avvincente nel mio piccolo stava
sperimentando qualcosa che va link in
larga scala il modo che ha utenti quel
genuino per raggiungere il successo e
realizzazione e metter a frutto le
proprie passioni
a quel punto ho riguardato indietro a
tutto quello che era successa in così
poco tempo fino ad arrivare a quella
domanda del primo giorno di lezione vi
ricordate perché quale motivo di tutta
questa
euforia quel fuoco quella esplosione di
determinazione la risposta che mi sono
dato è insita nel mio modo di essere e
nei valori con cui sono cresciuto dei
valori con cui tutti noi siamo cresciuti
è la cultura della condivisione
ci sono degli oggetti o o dei beni in
senso astratto che se danno spartiti tra
più persone invece di svalutarsi
acquisiscono un valore un concerto beh
il type questo evento o una canzone un
libro un viaggio oppure è un'esperienza
un'opinione anche un momento di silenzio
una passione un talento la felicità tra
questi beni
c'è anche la conoscenza avevo ritrovato
il valore e la passione della conoscenza
nella condivisione della conoscenza e la
mia mente sarà messo in movimento
proprio in un momento in cui avevo
cercato di mettere in movimento le menti
dei miei studenti in inghilterra è stata
un'esperienza fantastica
ora sto scrivendo la mia tesi di
dottorato conto di finire nei prossimi
mesi
e così un momento di decidere del mio
prossimo passo come avrete capito la
passione per l'insegnamento è grandiosa
però l'università non è l'unico luogo in
cui matematica e comunicazione si
incontrano per dar vita questa magia
della condivisione della conoscenza ma
staremo a vedere e raccontato questo
capitolo della mia storia proprio perché
penso che quello che ho imparato è
condivisibile metodi montecarlo a parte
per esempio il fatto di intraprendere un
percorso che poi non si rivela quello
che chiedevamo oppure trovare finalità e
motivazione attraverso strade che non
c'è anche non c'eravamo aspettati e poi
certo la passione come catalizzatore dei
nostri talenti e la cultura della
condivisione
c'è un'ultima cosa che voglio
condividere con voi e per farlo l'invito
a lezione
è una lezione preparazione all'esame di
finanza ci sono più di cento studenti in
aula io entro di buon umore e dvd rigo
alla cattedra e si stava bene il
microfono sfoderò i miei tre pennarelli
colorati
allo scoccare dell'ora mi schiarisco la
voce cesa silenzio spiego che
l'esercitazione a coperta lato ci
permetterà di passare tutti i punti
chiave del corso una ragazza in prima
fila mi chiede se possa dare qualche
indizio sulle domande d'esame
io l'esame non l'ho visto ma passato il
sabato notte arrivò a rivedere gli esami
dei cinque anni passati ho raccolto
tutto quello che possono aspettarsi su
uno schema lo potranno avere a fine
lezione un altro ragazzo poche indietro
il che da dove può trovare altri
esercizi per prepararsi è vero abbiamo
avuto poco tempo per la pratica ma c'è
molto materiale in internet e dove
trovarlo
l'ho scritto sul retro dello schema sono
soddisfatti bene inizia lo show io
scrivo alla lavagna ma spesso mi rivolgo
a loro per chiedere come procedere ogni
punto del pil della pratica richiama un
elemento di teoria che li passiamo tutti
quanti insieme
qualcuno fa una domanda acuta molto
difficile ma io ho passato la domenica
sul loro libro di testo sono ben
preparato me la cavo scherzo con loro
per fargli prendere per fargli prendere
respiro ed una direzione vola gli faccio
l'in bocca al lupo per l'esame
un gruppo di studenti si ferma qualcuno
che le dei chiarimenti ma la maggior
parte solo delle rassicurazioni un
ultimo studente mi si avvicina e salvino
lui esito nel parlare sembra straniero
forse sta testando le parole giuste
alla fine trova il coraggio solo per
dirmi chiara io voglio solo dirti grazie
perché quello che tu fai per noi non lo
fa nessuno
rimango solo in aula e o un sorriso
immenso e un cuore ancorato gigante e
penso che forse è proprio quello al mio
posto a questo mondo
ecco questo voglio dirvi mente e cuore
sono legati saldamente e per questo
motivo quando la mente in movimento
anche il cuore mi batte forte nel dentro
al tatto sono mente cuore in movimento
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]